i struggle with this with whether to
show this kind of thing or talk about it
because on one hand i don't want to call
attention to it and contribute
unintentionally to the problem but on
the other hand i don't want to ignore
the abuse of a child and let it go and
criticize and that brings us to
this viral video as reported by the
blaze quote
a video of a crowd applauding and
encouraging a young girl who is twerking
in the street in new york city
outraged many on social media who called
it abusive and immoral
the video was posted to a twitter
account but originated from an account
on tick tock called your fave african
fa whatever that is uh it shows a very
young girl twerking while the crowd
records videos applauds and laughs the
original video was first posted to tick
tock and only garnered 207 thousand
views
far fewer than those on the same video
posted to twitter and before we go any
further i'll show you the video just so
you understand
what we're dealing with here and here it
is
we all need this confidence in life
[Music]
now as the blaze alluded to plenty of
people were rightfully outraged by that
video the sexualization of a child by a
group of cheering adults
is the kind of thing that should provoke
outrage in the hearts and minds of all
good and decent people
we shouldn't react to we shouldn't react
to the perpetual outrage culture
as some do by deciding that apathy is
the best course
as if outrage in and of itself is the
problem
that's been the defense mechanism of
many people including many on the right
who wish to demonstrate their
non-leftist
bonafides by not objecting to or showing
any anger towards
our cultural decay now that that's the
wrong approach to put it mildly
the problem with outrage just as with
cancer culture is that it often targets
the wrong things
and it's wielded in the wrong ways i'm
not against people being outraged nor am
i against
getting people getting or things getting
canceled obviously
i'm against both of those when they're
disordered improper misapplied or
fraudulent or some combination
of the four but not everybody was
outraged by the video it did have its
defenders including a guy named pete
dominic
who apparently is a comedian of some
sort and
he came after me and accused me of being
worse than the taliban
because i said that the adults in that
video should be arrested
actually in fairness i said that if i
ever run for president my one promise is
that i will arrest all adults involved
in that sort of thing and that sort of
thing being the sexualization of
children
that's not entirely true though i would
do a few other things as well as
president
like build a 300-foot statue of
christopher columbus in the middle of dc
just out of spite
um and i'd ban us embassies from flying
pride flags or any flag that isn't an
american flag
i might do a few other things too but
certainly criminalizing the abuse and
exploitation of children in all forms
and imprisoning the abusers would be at
the top of the list
for this dominic accused me of being
worse than the taliban
and then he went on to argue that there
isn't anything necessarily wrong with
young children
twerking on the street corner and he's
not alone in that view
obviously he's not alone as the young
child in the video was surrounded by
adults
who clearly felt at the the same way
about the situation
what we have to understand about a video
like that
is that it's not an aberration it's not
something that happens out of the blue
in an otherwise decent and morally
adjusted culture
now this is born from primarily two
factors
one the blurring of lines blurring of
the lines of distinction between adults
and children
in our culture kids are routinely
exposed to all kinds of degeneracy that
even adults in prior generations
would have never seen or heard or
encountered in any form and now kids at
very young ages
are exposed to it meanwhile kids are
given power and agency that they are not
equipped to handle as discussed in the
opening
they're given the power even to decide
their own identity
so the idea of the innocence and naivete
of children has been lost meanwhile two
the role of adults of parents has been
similarly blurred into oblivion
many parents these days think that their
job is simply to facilitate their
children's choices
whatever those choices happen to be and
ensure at least a basic level of
physical safety maybe as the kids go
about living however they want to live
and doing whatever they want to do
this is the kind of environment that
we've created and it gives rise to many
terrible things
that video being just one rotten fruit
from that tree
i hope i don't have to go any further to
explain the problem with what we just
witnessed
or to justify myself in saying that all
of the adults involved there
uh are cancelled and quite a lot more
would happen to them
if i was in a position of authority
which fortunately for uh for everyone
probably i never will
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated